네, 안녕하세요.
빌사남매노크 김수입니다. 어, 이번
시간에는 대선이 지금 얼마 남지
않았는데 그 대선 후보들의 부동산
공략에 대해서 좀 알아보고 제
개인적인 생각까지 여러분들한테 좀
알려 드리도록 하겠습니다.
빌사남의 노크.
그리고 사실 이게 되게 조심스러워요.
되게 정치적인 부분이고 그런 부분이
좀 있긴 하지만 아무래도 저희가
부동산을 가지고 있거나 아니면 부동산
투자하실 분들한테는 중요한 부분이기
때문에 오늘 좀 그 주제로 이야기를
좀 해 보려고 합니다. 우선 첫
번째로 재건축 재개발에 대해서
공략들을 좀 볼 거예요. 제가 일단
후보는 세 명으로 정했습니다. 첫
번째 이재명 후보, 두 번째 김문수
후보, 세 번째 이준석 후보. 이렇게
세 명 공략을 주로 좀 말씀드릴 거고
일단은 새 후보 다 완화하겠다라는
얘기를 다들 했어요. 김문수 후보
같은 경우에는 그 시군에 좀
위임하겠다라고 해서 그 시군가 좀
이렇게 자체적으로 사업을 할 수
있게끔 그런 얘기를 좀 했었고 그리고
이준석 후보 같은 경우에는 용적률을
정말 확 올려 주겠다. 재건축
재개발에 대해서는 이준석 후보가 되게
완화적인 얘기들을 좀 많이 했습니다.
그리고 이재명 후보 같은 경우에는
물론 이제 완화를 해 준다라고 했지만
조금 이제 밸런스를 맞춰서 풀어
주겠다라는 식으로 좀 얘기를
했습니다. 그 두 번째로는 무엇보다
여러분들 세금이 되게 중요한 거
같아요. 네. 그래서 세금 얘기를 좀
해 보자면 우선 첫 번째로 이재명
후보 같은 경우에는 기존 세율을 좀
유지하겠다. 그리고 상황에 따라서
조금 조정을 하겠다라는 식으로 좀
얘기를 했습니다. 그리고 이제 김문수
후보 같은 경우에는 엄청 완화해
주겠다라는 얘기를 좀 많이 했어요.
그래서 종부세를 완화해 주겠다.
양도세를 줄여 주겠다. 세금 완화적인
얘기를 좀 되게 많이 했습니다.
그리고 이준석 후보 같은 경우에는
오랫동안 보유한 사람들은 세금 혜택을
주겠다. 그러니까 이제 뭐 장기 보유
특별 공제를 올려 주겠다라는 식으로
좀 얘기를 했어요. 서 조금 정리를
해 보자면 이재명 후보는 기존 세율를
좀 유지하는 방향 쪽으로 좀 얘기를
했고 김문수 후보 같은 경우에는 진짜
종부세라든지 양도세를 엄청 줄여
주겠다. 엄청 적극적으로 완화적인
얘기를 좀 많이 했고 이준석 후보는
완화는 해 주는데 보유한 사람 위주로
좀 해 주겠다라는 식으로 세금적인
부분은 좀 얘기를 했습니다. 그리고
세 번째로 상업용 부동산의 공략을
발표했던 거 중에 일단 첫 번째로
이재명 후보 같은 경우에는 상가
임차인을 보호하겠다라는 정책을 좀
얘기를 했어요. 뭐 이런 상가 임대차
보호법이라든지 이런 거를 좀 바꾸지
않을까 그렇게 좀 예상을 하고 그리고
김문수 후보 같은 경우에는 주거용
오피스텔 저희가 이제 오피스텔로
인해서 뭐 취득세가 중가되거나 주거
세금을 납부하는 경우 되게 많거든요.
근데 그런 거를 완화해 주겠다라는
얘기들을 좀 많이 했습니다. 그리고
이준석 후보 같은 경우에는 지방에
이렇게 미분양이나 상가 공실들이 되게
많은데 분양이 아니라 조금 임대로
전환하거나 아니면 다른 방향으로 좀
바꾸겠다 뭐 이런 이야기들을 좀 많이
했습니다. 네. 그래서 좀 정리를 해
보면 김은수 후보 같은 경우에 이제
뭐 역시나 이제 계속 좀 완화적인
그런 뉘앙스로 좀 얘기를 많이 했고
그 이재문 후보 같은 경우에는 상가
임차인 보호에 대한 얘기를 좀 많이
했고 그 이준수 후보는 고질적인 공실
부분 아니면 미분양 부분을 좀 다른
방법으로 좀 유동성 이렇게게 바꾸는
그런 정책에 대해서 좀 얘기를
했습니다. 정책은요 정도까지만
얘기하겠습니다. 그래서 여러분들이이
정책을 들어 보시고 여러분들이 알아서
좀 판단하시면 될 거 같아요. 그래서
그냥 저는 공약들을 얘기했던 거를 좀
정리해서 말씀드렸고 어 그래서 앞으로
좀 어떻게 될 거 같냐 뭐 이런
질문들도 좀 많이 받아요. 개인적으로
생각을 좀 말씀드리자면 단기적으로는
크게 변동이 없을 것 같아요. 이런
정책들이 하나하나가 시간이 좀 오래
걸려요. 그래서 단기적으로는 큰
변화가 없을 것 같다라는게 제
의견이고. 근데 그것보다 저는 더
중요한게 금리나 경제 상황이 더 클
거 같습니다. 뭐 윤성열 정부 때도
다 완화해 주는 정책으로 하긴 했는데
그때 이제 금리가 확 오르기도 했고
경제 상황이 워낙 안 좋다 보니까
부동산 가격이 좀 내려갔거든요. 어
이런 많은 후보분들의 공략이 있지만
그거보다는 지금 금리나 경기 상황이
좀 영향이 더 클 것 같습니다.
그래서 앞으로 금리라든지 경기 상황을
좀 여러분들이 더 지켜보시면 좋을 것
같고 그런 짓물도 많이 받아요. 지금
살고 있는 집을 팔아서 건물을
사겠다. 뭐 이런 분들도 있어요.
근데 저는 자신있게 말씀드릴 수 있는
거는 내가 살고 있는 집을 팔아서
빌딩 사는 거는 진짜 바보 같은
행위입니다. 왜냐면 장기보유 특별
공제율이 되게 높아요. 주택은.
건물은 장기보 특별 공제율이 최대치
다 받아도 30%거든요. 근데 주택은
80%입니다. 그래서 장기보유 특별
공제율이 워낙 높기 때문에 집을
팔아서 사는 건 아닌 거 같고 차라리
서울시에 대단지에 똘똘한 아파트를
하나 사 놓고 그 이후에 뭔가 여유
자금이 생기면은 이런 빌딩 투자하는
쪽으로 넘어가는게 맞지? 내가 살고
있는 집까지 다 팔아 가지고 빌딩을
사는 건 좀 아닌 거 같습니다. 네.
그래서 여러분들이 후보들의 부동산
공약도 좀 유심히 보시고 그리고
앞으로 내가 부동산 투자하데 있어서
이분들이 앞으로 부동산 공약을 어떻게
할 건지를 좀 참고해서 부동산 투자를
좀 하셨으면 좋겠습니다. 그리고 내가
예를 들어서 뭐 아파트를 투자할 수도
있고 빌딩을 투자할 수도 있고 뭐
토지를 투자할 수도 있고 뭐 여러
종류의 이런 부동산을 투자를 할 수
있잖아요. 그 후보들이내는 그런
정책들도 되게 부동산 투자에 있어서
되게 중요한 요소거든요. 그래서
여러분들이 이런 후보들의 부동산
공약들을 좀 세심하게 보신 다음에
앞으로 부동산 투자하 있어서 어
참고가 되셨으면 좋겠습니다. 그래서
오늘 영상은 여기까지 하고요. 다음
시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다.